[Music]
came to make this
phone I Cole called Tom
MC just cold called cold email okay yeah
it was uh uh yeah I was a
big uh I I I was just going through a
bit of an obsession with with Tom and
Jim probably 2020 at the beginning of
the
pandemic and uh what kind through their
writing their writing well the full
story is I don't know if I've I've told
Frank this I told Jimmy this but I I was
a a parrot head in like sixth grade like
a massive Jimmy Buffett fan and went
through a pirate phase where I I took
the bed out of my room and and put a
hammock in there and wanted to get
tattoos on the back of my eyelids so
people would think I was
awake based on a character on one of
Jimmy's books y but in that book he
talks about his brother-in-law Tom MCU
but I had misread that as Roger
McGuinn for 20 something years I thought
Jimmy was brother-in-laws with the guy
from The Birds okay until someone sent
me some horses which is a collection of
short stories of TOMS later on in my
life and that that took me back full
circle to some of his literature and and
Jim's poetry and the tarpon film so a
tarpon guide gave me Tom's email and I
just reached out ask if he'd be
interested in me coming to visit him so
are you from Florida or from the Key
West I'm from Texas I'm from Texas okay
so I had never heard of Tarpon the fish
or this kind of fishing can you talk
about it's a catch and release type of
fishing catch and release and they're
just huge you know 200 anywhere between
120 to 300 lb prehistoric looking fish
okay and um I mean very hard to catch
very hard to catch they're very crafty
yeah they they're and it is it's like a
battle it's like an athletic event and
uh it's pretty
special it's like the I mean I think in
in hunting it would be you know bow
hunting with an elk where it's it's hard
to I mean it's requires hunting and and
stalking and and then the the hardest
tool you could possibly find to do it is
the equivalent of tarpon fishing so I
think once you
continually to excel that's the ultimate
Challenge as a Outdoorsman is tarpon
fishing so was is Tom MCU the the the
first person of this group who kind of
went to Key
West uh discovered that he liked it
there and then he invited all the rest
of this group is that kind of how it
came to
be yeah I'm not sure he invited
themed found their way there on their
own I know Jimmy came down with Jerry
Jeff
Walker and um you know for me this
movies is about friendship and Jimmy and
Jerry Jeff were friends from that moment
that he took them uh Tom and Jim Jimmy
and I he was my best friend and so when
so you're part of this friend group too
then well yeah I mean and it was really
the beginning of the year Jimmy and I go
way back we've known each other since
1980 and and we we just love to share
the worlds that we live in and work in
and so I go to him for music questions
and he comes to me for film questions
and last January he said hey they
discovered this movie that that uh the
Frenchman um Christian Christian had
shot and I had I knew Christian's
daughter and everybody knows everybody
in the Jimmy Tom world and he said you
know would you take a look and see what
you think and I looked at this and you
know as a documentary filmmaker you
go I'm looking for these gems these
little lost treasures and there was this
movie and here were these guys and Scott
had
the the you know smarts and
the the
persistence to go after this because he
saw a story there and the story and then
Tom you know none of these guys want to
talk on camera right they don't want
they go who are you I don't want to talk
about this can I have final cut that's
the other no you can't it's a
documentary that's why we're and and he
sent me this the rough cut and I went oh
my God this is gold this is yeah I'm
happy to you know be involved however
you want me to be involved so that's how
it started
and yeah it was a gamble when I started
with Tom I didn't I hadn't been in touch
with Jimmy or knew that I had access to
the film so it was a bit of a like Frank
says a persistent leap of faith so so
she shows the the film in its state when
it's sort of like vinegar syndrome uh
you know like encrusted and and so was
it in that state when you heard that
there was a film and then did did you to
wait for the footage to be like restored
and it wasn't in that state it would it
had been at some point in the 90s they
had um burnt some DVDs that I think they
melt out through some you know website
and that got pirated and it like you
know the the quality was not great back
then so we had a version of that that we
sent off and got restored and brought up
to 4K and color corrected and those were
copies that she had in the um uh those
were negatives but so it it was in a
little better state to to start with but
not a lot of people had seen it the T I
feel like the tarpon fishing
film sort of brings everything together
it sort of weaves everything because
there's just like so many out there's so
many different people in this group um
musicians and writers and with all their
own lives but they were all a part of
this like section of life and this part
of the world and um I think it's really
interesting because I feel like a lot of
60s and for some reason a lot of people
that were part of like the folk music or
folk art scene aren't that well known
now so when I see a film like this it
introduces me to people that I didn't
know about like I knew about Richard
bradigan and I knew Carl H's work and of
course jmy Buffett but I had never heard
of Tom
mcu's work before and I I think that um
sometimes um I don't know why do do you
have an opinion about sometimes why
certain writers are well I think um uh
affordability it's like like you know
you gravitate I when I was trying to
explain to them what I had in mind my
analogy was there's a you know I'm from
Austin Texas and there's a film called
heartworn highways you know and it was
like towns Van's an and Guy Clark and a
bunch of like-minded musicians who all
lived in in Austin at that time and
they're swapping songs and you know it
was cheap to live in Austin and there
was this spirit and this funkiness and
this Bohemia so you know there's in
whether it's Paris in the 20s or Austin
with Willie and those guys or Key West I
think there's certain you know funky
Bohemian places that are cheap to live
in that attract you know uh artists and
you know I think Tom was the first one
down there to fish but Jimmy came down
there on his own and I think you know a
lot of people discover Tom's writing and
uh you know Jim's writing or some of
these other writings but I think there's
a whole you know there's a lot of people
that only know Jimmy after 1985 and he's
got five incredible albums in this era
that I think you know a most people
aren't aware of that are that are as
good as anything tal F wrote or any of
those guys that I think I hope this film
turns on to to people to like he was a a
real artist and Tom that's the the only
about Final Cut the only thing that
still bugs Tom about the movie is
there's some clever editing when we're
talking about Jimmy making the best
sellers list and it makes it look like
you know Jim and and Tom were
disappointed or threatened and I think
they were really happy clearly like the
the joke is that these guys were too you
know they were just against each other
competitive po poets serious poet and
jimmmy comes in from the back and just
but uh there there was like a healthy
brotherly competition that elevated
everyone and I think they they truly
they truly loved each other but it's
like I think the this film was about um
then maybe not really real you know men
aren't great at communicating that or
even being aware of that at the time and
you know Jim had just died when we
started filming it um Richard bran is
clear Tom MCU hadn't even thought about
that and then the the week we finished
editing ghee passed away and the the
night we premiered it Jimmy passed away
wow yeah in torite we were all inorite
was the most amazing he passed away the
N of year Premiere yeah during the Q&A
uh oh
yeah that happened we just filmed I
don't know if I told you this but we
filmed it in Key West last week at the
Key West film festival and Jimmy's
daughters were there and his sisters and
Tom's family and we we filmed it it was
supposed to be a double feature in
another film afterwards but we filmed it
and right when Tom and I got up for the
Q&A the electricity went out the entire
Island and yeah it was spooky yeah well
Jimmy was there yeah no more movies
after my
movie cutting
it I just think yeah it's um when you
talk it's interesting when you talk
about
the the two of them being competitive I
think you know you find that a lot in
groups of artists they sort of Drive
each they their competition drives them
to be like the best writers or the best
you
know crafts people that they can be
because they have someone else they're
trying to do a oneup yeah and I like to
look at it as it inspires them to
another level I'm I'm doing a a beach
boys do
and the The Beach Boys had never heard
of The
Beatles And when the Beatles came on the
scene they were just to them it was just
this other band and they went whoa now
we got to you know got to step it up and
they became not Rivals and not but ins
they inspired each other and there
wouldn't I don't think there'd be
Sergeant Peppers without pet sacks I
could be wrong but they the way they all
talk about and the way Paul talks about
it um so it was kind of like that
healthy friendly competition that they
inspired each other to write and they
would share each other's you know
like work and and critique each other's
work and it made it better and steal
from it as you saw but I think there's
other take like and I'm sure I think as
an artist it's like the people I've seen
that have been successful at it aren't
making it they're not their their target
isn't for everyone they had one person
in mind that they're trying to they want
to like you know if there's one if there
you know I'm sure that you have like
maybe someone you're married to or
someone that you're um someone that you
you work with that as a contemporary
that that you're you have them in mind
like I want them to like this movie and
if that person likes it then the odds
are is someone but I feel like a lot of
people I know that are artists like I've
got a friend that I know of like if I
send a song or movie to like that's
that's who it's for and then if that's a
success then it it will and I feel like
these guys were like that too they were
were so insular and so bright and
intelligent that they were often times
what they were writing or singing you
know Jimmy would be bring a song to them
first before it went to anyone else yeah
I feel like so many people of this
particular era like this group of people
were
all all of these people seem very
connected to Nature they all seem very
connected to
to being outdoors and with nature did
you ever think about like the all these
writers and musicians and their
relationships with with nature and they
sort of
like it's like they all sort of in got
inspiration off of being outside like is
that what attracted you to this group of
people do you relate to that I relate to
it yeah absolutely and and I think all
those guys
authentically you know again going back
to like characteristics of of of
successful artists I know they they use
the other to inspire you know to inspire
it and like there Jimmy was clearly a
nautical ocean dweller and and the music
and the themes that he sang about were
were very genuine and I think it's hard
to just be in a studio and create
meaningful art and I think same thing
with Tom who had spend half the year in
a river on a boat fishing like to to
have that time to gather your
inspiration to go out to do it I think
they there's there's a lot of value in
that than Hing way was definitely known
for that too to be outside fishing doing
all outdoor stuff yeah I'm interested in
Dynamic people that have more interest
than the thing that they're U did you
think that was particularly of that era
where a lot of artists were connected to
Nature like more so than it is now now
where artists find themselves inspired
by Nature I think there's still plenty
of it out there I think there's it's a
good I think it's
harder I don't know it's like there's um
I think there's there's a lot of people
there's a guy that I'm I'm friends with
named goth babe that's a successful
musician that's a sailor and fly
fisherman and there's there's a lot of
folks that I think uh still find a way
to blend those those two worlds um I
think there's a lot of value do in
it do you guys fly fish I do I don't my
grandpa was a fly Fisher I'm pretty
bored with fishing
all my grandpa was a fly fisherman he
made his own flies he had waiters he had
several pairs of like the hip waiter
things um which you know I I I did a lot
of fishing but not fly fishing it looks
very hard and well even Jimmy and Tom I
think they had different approaches to
fly fishing yeah I think Tom was a very
serious fly Fisher and Jimmy was he had
drones out and paddle boards and GS and
I think he was having fun with Jimmy was
a
multitasker add um you know he whenever
we play golf he he'd find a way to play
about six holes about half of each hole
and then he'd pick it up and we goes he
was just out there to say he played golf
the same way with his fishing although
he was very serious about bone fishing
yeah he loved to Bone Fish but he was
also it's kind of the same thing with
tarpons u it's a you know kind of a
sport okay but he what Jimmy loved to do
was sail I I love to sail I grew up in
Newport and I do I do share that love of
the ocean and I know that it's it's like
freedom and it does open you up I think
and to your thinking and and that was
the thing about Jimmy he was authentic
and genuine what he wrote about and the
the life he led and his lifestyle was
authentic and and I think he gave that
spirit and and he told me at the end
just keep it going keep the party going
keep that Spirit going don't don't feel
bad for me so we're trying to do that
sweet it's not easy but we're trying to
do it Frank mentioned that that none of
these guys want to talk why is that so
first part of the question is why don't
they want to talk and second part is how
do you as a documentary filmmaker get
them to tell the stories that you want
them to tell well um well that's kind of
how we had the opportunity there there
the whole the the um the tarpon film was
a failure in the film like the the
filmmaker wanted to go make a film about
writers and no one want they wouldn't
talk or they were on Tom was on so much
acid that they couldn't find him and his
his voice over was inaudible so they had
to have Jim redo it that's gim voices so
they had they came all the way over to
France to film it and uh they the the
writers gave them I think half a day so
it ended up being a fishing film but so
I think in one way what I this version
is is one giving context of those guys
in that in that film but also I think a
version of that film that I think they
would have liked to write that's more in
depth on the writing and the friendship
I don't know I think people that are you
know I think someone you might have said
it or Tom said it but Jimmy had no rear
viw mirror Tom had no rear viw mirror
like people some people are very that
are that productive and and present and
creative like it's it's they don't spend
a lot of time sitting around thinking
about the the past or feeling the need
to to talk about it when you know
they're um so I just don't I think they
were interested in the next thing he
would tell me all day long about a new
you know cup holder idea he has first
his paddle board for his drink he hold
your drone and yeah no no he's a gadget
man too I mean he was just curious about
everything and on the way over I was
listening to one of his songs the oldest
Surfer on the beach you know that was
him he just kept surfing he kept he
paddle boarding you know keep going
forward keep going forward don't look in
the river mirror I think the answer to
your question I think I caught them at a
really interesting time with with Co
where we had some time to reflect on all
that for the first time Tom mom had just
lost an ex-wife a best friend you know I
think I think Co was the first time they
became aware that it's not forever and
that uh they felt isolated and started
probably realizing that it was the um
the best time of their lives and and
friendship you know they've they've
since went on and made really intense
lifelong friendships but friendships at
a certain age just can't be duplicated
and that's like a bond forever and I
think all I just I just came in at a
time where that was the first time
they've had a minute to to uh think
about that and I I think that was I
didn't quite know what the film was
going to be about until we were editing
Ben and our editors here and we found
some ver moments of Tom saying I don't
like old pictures yeah and that to me
became the whole the whole film of of it
going from that to him thinking about it
and being yeah cuz his wife says you're
you're not no nostalgic yeah he's like
he really wasn't no even in his Q&A he's
like
whoa It's he's yeah he he's not
nostalgic he's he's not
um I don't know he's just he's he's not
sentimental sental he definitely not I
feel like we associate writers with
Nostalgia so much so it's It's Curious
it's interesting to think of a writer
who's not
really nostalgic it's weird I those guys
were I mean if you go they were they
were for thinking out there guys all of
them I mean Jimmy too and like they were
you know before Hunter S Thompson uh uh
Tom's writing was like the precursor to
that but denser and harder to understand
but just as out there and just as like
lace with drug F you know well I and I
think you're right that there are these
little pockets of of time and people
Laurel Canyon is another one right I
mean that's never going to happen again
it happened then uh and this Key West
thing with these writers and granted you
know I I mean I guess because Jimmy had
had a couple of hit books they were all
writers and you know why they were there
we don't know it's all about serendipity
coincidence whatever you want to call it
but it's that little pocket of time and
and there was this footage that none of
us had ever seen it was fantastic from
this movie that never got saw the the
light of day and was and that's what you
love when you're making a dock yeah I
know a guy who's a chef and he moved to
Key West purely because he wanted to die
for his own food that's why he moved
there you go he he Dives for spiny
lobsters yeah that's his like passion
and he's a chef and he loves food so he
kind of like mixed his like all of his
desires together but he just had the
stream of I want to dive for my own fa
like everything there's a lot of free
Spirits down there yeah right um so the
part in the movie that you know made me
tear up a lot is the the sequence where
someone's um reading the poem and
someone's like standing out on the on a
hillside or something what what poem or
book is that sequence from that was from
uh the poem's called Hard Times by Jim
Harrison okay and we you know it was
believe it or not even Jimmy who's got
to have the most archives out of anyone
I knew there wasn't a lot of footage to
pull from um there wasn't a lot of old
photos that I had access to I mean I
would love to you know I I think this is
the right length of film for this
specific friendship and era but you know
there there will be longer films made
about you know you know Jimmy and
certainly each each guy can have his own
long long story um but so we were kind
of just finding trying to find whatever
we could and I think maybe our editor
Bennett found this old news clip from
local Montana news of Jim reading that
poem so um I thought and then so the
next shoot I went to Montana and had Tom
read it I also had Tom read what he
wrote and read at Jim funeral and then
went back to analou uh but which is in
Paradise Valley where a lot of those
guys hung out and did that drone just
hoping that it might connect and see if
there's a way to do that but yeah it was
beautiful yeah Jim's a great
writer well congratulations to you too
thank you um I had some people asking me
if this has like a streaming home yet or
if it has have you decided what its life
will be outside of this or not yet
um not yet okay there's any streaming
streaming homes out in the
audience yeah tell your friends are
there any questions that from the eyes
anybody yeah how did Frank how did you
meet Jimmy
oh okay the quick story is
um Aspen
1980 uh after Raiders um
Stephen uh and Harrison Ford and his
um his girlfriend at the time Elissa
maton were in Aspen and they invited
Stephen to come
ski uh it must have
been 1980 so it would have been December
of
1980 and Steven sent Kathy and I to set
up the cond
uh at the bottom of uh little Nell and
so and Harrison was there with Melissa
and so we were skiing and setting up
this thing and Stephen kept saying I'll
come tomorrow I'll be there tomorrow we
had you know four-wheel drives and ski
passes and skis and everything well he
never came so so we had this great time
there and on new years's Harrison said
well come to this this there's this this
New Year's party
and uh it's private party and there'll
be all these people there so I Kathy and
I went we weren't together at that time
but we were there and uh and had all
just made Raiders together so we were
great friends so we went and we went and
Kathy and I kind of sat in the back and
this was a wild party where the Eagles
were playing uh uh Andy Warhol was there
stamping pictures there were all these
crazy people there and Jimmy was there
and I didn't know I I finally told him
about 20 years ago I had never heard of
him I didn't know Monday was his only
song so anyway the night was
over and and it turns out that the party
had been thrown by Jane Buffett Jimmy's
wife so um but she left
early and they lived down Valley and so
we were out getting in our car here came
this guy like you know like he probably
was in Key West with his guitar in a
case and coming out looking around like
how do I get home and I said well we
we'll take you so we gave him a ride
home and the next
week um
this gift arrived at amlin and it was a
tour jacket a nicely embroidered tour
jacket about somewhere over China it was
a beautiful jacket and it was from Jimmy
it said thanks for looking out for me oh
and I thought who is this guy I want to
get to know this guy and that was start
of a beautiful
friendship
wow that's a great story thanks for
sharing that and when is Tarpon
shot 73 oh I think it's it said the the
link at the end of the movie where you
could watch the whole thing right is it
yeah I think they're going to put out
the full thing too is it feature length
it's 60 Minutes 60 how agus V kind of
feel to
it yeah it's
uh yeah they were he was I mean I think
Christian had like I said it worked he
worked for um Orson Wells and was a very
like uh you know I think Ardent ver um
you know not really manufacturing
anything was a lot of Silence a lot of
just like the sound design and just the
sound that they got with two guys was
incredible um but yeah it's it's it'll
it'll be out there I think the hope is
to to re-release that whenever this
finds a home or is distributed and I
think most people will probably be
inclined to go back and watch that whole
thing after watching this yeah
absolutely but we did use a lot of the
footage yeah I'm curious about uh bran
um I know he spent time in the Montana
uh as well I didn't know he spent time
in Key West but he's such a different
writer than than Harrison and mcne did
did he even though he was successful did
he fit in with those guys to me it seems
like a very different sort he did I from
what I can tell is you can't out weird
those guys everyone everyone was unfazed
by everything and I think back then they
were all pretty out there um and I think
I think Tom met bran in in bolus maybe
or may because Tom I think went to
Stanford at some point they met on the
west coast and I think he lived in Japan
at some point but I think they
acknowledged him as the weirdest but um
I think there was even some you know his
writing was was pretty esoteric and out
there um but I think all those guys kind
of they were all on some weird similar
wavelength and um you know uh you
weren't you weren't going to offend
anyone in that crowd the story that he
told about about Richard bran and the
N when when I watched it I I took it as
bran was telling him that he was going
to kill himself but is that the way that
Tom took it or no I don't think so I
don't think Tom I think if Tom you know
I'm sure that's a it was a abbreviated
story I don't think Tom would have just
allowed him to go to Japan and and
knowing that that was going to unfold um
you know um but I think I think he was
one of those guys that when the phone
rang no one was
surprised um and and it was a long time
coming and and I think there was plenty
of efforts to try to uh steer him back
in a a better
Direction but I don't know I I would
imagine the way that those guys
communicate and
how uh you know Shifty I I doubt it was
really presented to Tom is this is my
ear and right this my ashes will come in
here when I kill myself just just the
cryptic someone's going to call you for
this yeah it made me want to do that to
one of my friends be like to give them
an object be like someone's going to
call
you well there's no one I i' I think
they all the common threat I think Jim
was the king of turns of phrases and Tom
was the king with words like I don't
think I met anyone better with even his
emails I print out sometimes and just
keep he's he's really
articulate so who knows what Richard
really said
else okay we're wrapping up well thank
you thank
[Applause]
[Music]
you